Now, in the last exercise, we only looked
at four individual SNVs in the genome. But
now, let's imagine that we expand our comparisons
from just four SNVs, to 1 million SNVs across
the genome. Then we have a lot more
statistical power behind our numbers. The SNVs that 23
and ME uses for genome comparisons. Are spread
all over the chromosomes in the genome. The autosomes,
the sex chromosomes, and the mitochondrial chromosome. Once
the SNVs have been determined for an individual, then
we can actually determine the IBS score between
any two people sampling from a million positions in
the genome. Now you may be surprised to
find that the IBS score, if we measure over
a million SNVs, the IBS score between you and
the most distantly related person we could find around
the world. You would still have an IBS score
of about 70%. Even after looking at all these
positions, 70% of them would be identical with another
person. The person that you're most distantly related to.
Now this is when we focus specifically on the
SNVs, the single-nucleotide variants, regions of the genome that
we know and expect there to be variation. Remember
the human genomes, though, are already more than 99% identical.
So even though we're sampling from regions, that we
know should be different, and in general we do find
differences between humans here. Humans just aren't that different from
each other. And the IBS score between you and most
humans will be about 70% or higher. So if
the background IBS score for you and the most distantly
related person is about 70%, then I want you to
assume minimal inbreeding and tell me what you would expect
your IBS score to be between you and one of
your biological parents. About 70, 75, 85, 95, or 100%? I
want you to pick the answer that you think is
best and then tell me why in this text box here.